aber wir können eine punkte
herausgreifen nämlich die frage waffen
ich bin heute von estnischen kollegen
angesprochen worden warum gibt die
berlin jetzt das hat nichts mit merkel
zu tun hat nichts mit der union zu tun
die seit einigen jahrzehnten amtierende
regierungsentscheidung warum gibt man
ein grünes licht für das liefern von
estnischen waffen die aus alten in
warabi ständen bestehen es wird in der
welt wahrgenommen als eine verweigerung
deutschlands dass man eben die ukraine
nicht zur seite stehen korrigieren sie
sagen doch investoren nach sicherheit zu
gehen könnte auch in reifen liefern uns
in der situation gar nichts bringen
sagen auf die amerikanische seite nicht
dass der konflikt militärisch
entschieden werden könnte oder sollte
sondern das verhindert werden muss dass
es dazu kommt und dass wir harte
sanktionen vereinbaren für den fall dass
es anders kommt mit waffen die vor etwas
zu verändern militärisch das finden
nicht nur die amerikanische seite
richtig und die deutsche wurde ist es
nicht wahr verschiedene nicht nur den
wagen mit dem daneben liegt das stimmt
nicht waffenlieferungen sind ja an
erster stelle ja diese starke
solidaritäts beistands bekundung und ich
denke denke dass das genau das zeichen
ist deswegen haben die us amerikaner ja
auch so umfangreich waffen geliefert und
wir haben eine große wirtschaftliche
unterstützung geleistet das ist die
solidaritäts bekommen die wir auch noch
ausgeweitet ich sag noch mal mit waffen
die herzschläge nicht herstellen oder
fein hacken herr stegner
darf ich einen haken ja also danke für
ihre these für die hilfe also diese
hilfe ist etwas so was wir heute
benötigen also wie heute brauchen wir
nicht nur ihre schönen worte nicht nur
diese solidarischen bekundungen wir
brauchen waffen für die verteidigung und
diese waffen die deutschen liefern
könnte sie diese waffen werden uns nach
wie vor verweigert sogar die niederlande
die auch eine ähnliche position hatten
sie haben vor wenigen tagen ihre meinung
geändert und liefern gerade jetzt die
defensiv war von an die ukraine deswegen
ich kann hier nur folgendes sagen es ist
eine keine schöne ausrede jetzt sich zu
berufen darauf was deutschland vor acht
jahren getan hat dass man sein wie
schätzen diese hilfe aber im moment ist
es gefordert dass das die ukraine
wirklich in der lage gebracht werden
also widerstand zu leisten werden morgen
britische truppen tatsächlich eingreifen
sollten und deswegen es kommt jetzt
darauf an uns zu stärken die menschen
warten auf diese unterstützung und ich
kann ihnen folgendes sagen wenn
deutschland sich nach wie vor oder
weiterhin weigern wird und wenn putin
tatsächlich in den nächsten tagen oder
wochen einmarschiert das würde bedeuten
das versagen der deutschen außenpolitik
das wäre eine bankrotterklärung ihre
politik unter die ukraine werden diesen
fahrrad nie vergessen das sind harte
worte das heißt wenn es zu der invasion
zu dem einmarsch kommt sind sie schuld
mit herr stegner sagt er wenig bei allem
respekt herr botschafter ersten zehn
milliarden hilfen kann schön wurde so
sehen die ukraine streiten ich möchte
ihnen so trifft auf serena weiterleiten
verbot scharf an sie und an die ampel
geregelten zur botschaft daher nicht
dass auch zu ende führen darf die
ausreden lassen wenn man der festen
überzeugung ist es der konflikt
militärisch geführt entschieden werden
kann sind waffenlieferung jedenfalls
nicht der richtige weg und deswegen mit
deutschland das auch nicht wählen
liefern keine waffen in spannungsgebiete
auch nicht die ukraine sollen wir tun
alles und sie liefert war von allem eine
gemeinsame und seit jahren in
krisengebiete
heftigen tagen noch kein neuer
eigentliche frage da wenn wir
nacheinander wegen ich kann mir nichts
das ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wenn
sie das wie die deutsche öffentlichkeit
diesen diesen krieg und das schlafende
grinsen zivilisten jetzt live vor augen
sehen wird weil es wird ein krieg sein
also verlauf von der kamera und wenn sie
sehen dass die ukraine hätten sich
verteidigen können und sie haben das
unterlassen dass eine unterlassene
hilfeleistung unser gar im deutschen
recht ist das eine straftat herr stegner
deswegen ich möchte sie wirklich daran
erinnern dass solidarität heißt nicht
nur schöne worte zu sagen oder daran zu
erinnern dass die ukraine diese hilfe
bekommen hat das schätzen wir aber das
ist leider zu wenig was sie konnte ich
bin nicht der einzige in der runde
gehabt ist der konflikt nicht
militärisch gelöst werden kann aber das
ist jedenfalls meine position darum geht
sie brauchen sie nicht zu karikieren
basten liefern und installieren um die
verteidigung dass
die ukraine möchte keinen kriegen er
weber ganz kurze frage bevor wir hier
einmal kurz durchschnaufen eine kurze
pause machen das sagt andrej melik der
botschafter der ukraine er sagt wenn es
zu dem militärischen konflikt jetzt
kommt wenn es zu dem einmarsch kommt zur
invasion kommt wenn putin ernst macht
dann trägt die bundesregierung dafür
wesentliche verantwortung der verrat wie
er es nennt sie das
putin versteht nur die sprache der
stärke der macht das ist dass putin
versteht und diese sprache sprechen wir
derzeit nicht ich würde übrigens
durchaus weitergehen nicht nur wir
deutschen nicht sondern die europäer
insgesamt nicht wir sind auf die stürme
die in dieser welt da draußen auf uns
auf uns warten nicht vorbereitet und wir
sollten auch ganz ehrlich sein wir
können uns derzeit zurücklehnen weil wir
den amerikanischen schutzschirm haben
wir können diesen klären sind aus dem
internet beobachten weil wir eine
amerikanische schutzschirm wir haben
aber die ukraine können das nicht die
menschen dort wollen so lieben wie wir
leben dürfen in freiheit demokratie aber
sie werden jetzt bedroht von jemanden
der das unterdrücken will und insofern
wir sind nicht vorbereitet und der trägt
berlin derzeit auch mit der unklaren
haltung vor allem bei nordstream 2 eine
schwere verantwortung